stephen matson make his 27th start at
the season this is just his fourth start
here at rogers center and he set a new
career high with his 12th win last time
out on sunday
the pitch
got him swinging
matt strikes out buxton donaldson
and what he did for the blue jays here
for a number of years is acknowledged in
his first at bat this is nice
as donaldson hits the ball high in the
air deep right field that one's headed
for the seats and it's a home run josh
donaldson for the second game in a row
and the twins take a two-nothing lead
well he's had some great years in that
ballpark he knows exactly how to hit
there
stephen has not had too many issues in
the first innings this year
coming into this game he had the lowest
first inning era
at 138 third lowest in
the major leagues
different story here this afternoon
he strikes shot rooker bailey ober looks
comfortable he looks comfortable using
his fastball he's got a lot of trust in
that the low walk number is very good
deep to center
but not deep enough we got a man there
one down
gobbled up by donaldson and he'll throw
him out two gone
half swing did he go straight three
good inning for ober
as he sets the blue jays down one two
three
ground ball to short beschette to simeon
and a high throw
and it is out of the glove of guerrero
he tried to swipe down on polanco going
by but he just could not get it done a
little frustrated there
and now donaldson sends a flyable to
left field on the first pitch but guriel
is there so no damage done other than
one extra pitch that stephen mats has to
throw
and now the breaking ball strikes him
out
so that was perfect
no disrespect to valera but he's not
guerrero and you got ahead of him alone
too perfect time to try to work on a
pitch that you're going to need
quicker breaking ball nice pick up by
donaldson and he guns it across to
ostadio
two down eight up eight down for ober
and a nice play by the twins third
baseman
nice
that was a wonderful at bat for the
pitcher
and he strikes out springer let's see
what a difference the second time
through the order makes for toronto
we've seen simeon hit all year long and
he's a deadpool hitter
club to left field
number 40
for marcus simeon
as he continues his incredible season
for the blue jays what a milestone for
marcus his 40th home run on the year so
two on with the nobody out for t oscar
hernandez the pitcher hernandez swinging
a high fly ball out to deep left field
rooker back in front of the wall he will
leap in the air and it's gone
a go ahead three run homer forte oscar
hernandez
number 28 on the season
the blue jays have hit a pair of long
balls in the fourth
liner to center scorched another one
buxton's got to give ground and that's a
base hit just think about it the names
were talking about comparing beau and
vlady and
all these players to the greats of all
time that's pretty special line drive to
right and opposite field to base hit for
beshet guerrero up to second
this is to left rooker
tumbles and makes the catch
nice catch by rooker to end the inning
strand a couple of runners twins still
in it it's 4-2 big spot here in the
sixth inning blue jays four twins two
two out two on and out of the bullpen
comes trevor richards
weekly hit up the first baseline
richards two guerrero in time
and he will get this pivotal out and
strand a couple of runners here in the
sixth
to donaldson
to polanco to ostidio
and that'll take care of the inning
with moran getting the double play
grounded
doesn't make much difference left these
righties they all fare about the same
against mason
to center field randall gretchen coming
in makes the catch you know hazel may
talk about randall playing in center
field he's not committing an error in
the outfit at either center or right but
he has really played well
slider and a swing and a miss two down
when you throw as hard as he does and he
just threw a pitch outside that jeffers
waved at then you come back with this
slider very tight spin and you can see
that red dot on that baseball as it goes
toward the hitter 3-2 again to kirk up
and away ball four now cook
does a good job he doesn't chase that
pitch and gets on base once again and
starts the inning big o two pitch on the
way
and moran comes back strikes out simeon
with a nice change up one down
3-2
and he'll take another walk to load him
up
beau bechet is coming up with the bases
loaded guy that always comes through in
these tough spots
and that's a base hit into left field
jansen into score springer getting the
wave the throw comes into third big
two-run single for buchet 6-2 blue jays
the 1-0 hard ground ball towards the
shortstop backhanded by bow fade away
throw from the hole a dig by guerrero to
get the out how about that
what a throw
what a scoop
terrific play by machete even with a
four-run lead you want nothing left to
chance it's september you're in a race
so here comes jordan romano
and he makes quick work of cino exactly
what you want
sliding for the first pitch to get ahead
at two fastballs he just blows him away
[Applause]
he does throw him a slider grounded out
to simeon
to bechet for one and they won't get to
a fielder's choice for kepler
and that is now two outs here in the
ninth inning everybody on their feed at
rogers center with the blue jays on the
cusp of a
and there it win
romano blows away jeffers and the blue
chase bounced back from a defeat last
night and pick up a 6-2 win over the
minnesota twins here this afternoon